au lendemain de la journée mondiale sans
tabac notre reportage sur une cigarette
qui paraît-il est inoffensive
elle est en effet autorisée dans les
lieux publics il s'agit de la fameuse
cigarette électronique un inhalateur de
nicotine mais méfiance n'espérez pas
avec ce produit vous sevrer du tabac
patricia issa xavier roman
non non vous ne rêvez pas ce jeune homme
fume bien dans un lieu public et
personne ne lui dit rien pour cause
depuis deux mois
cyril dégaine sa cigarette électronique
où il veut quand il veut
tincques et j'aimerais fumée partout je
la tue fumée partout et puis surtout
j'ai pu c'est beaucoup plus agréable
après on n'a plus les sensations qu'on a
avec les cigarettes
au départ ça gêne un petit peu ça manque
d'après on a pu la bouche pâteuse on a
plus
y a plus le beurre et le losc est bien
content parce que chez soi ça sent bon
très agréable vous avez à une batterie
en gros une batterie un vaporisateur et
une cartouche de nicotine vous recharger
la batterie sera l'une cigares ou
électriques
et après ça chauffe et donc quand je
suis mais c'est la batte bordeaux qui
sort et valda fut belle mais cette
petite innovation provoque quelques
interrogations chez les médecins
d'autant que la publicité compare cette
cigarette électronique à un moyen de
sevrage tabagique
sauf que cette cigarette n'a subi aucun
test sanitaire pour le milieu médical
trouver un tel produit en vente va à
l'encontre de la sécurité du
consommateur se produit je ne sais pas
ce que c'est je sais qu'il ya trois
usines en chine qu'il fabrique mais on
ne sait pas ce cas là dedans il n'y a
pas eu d études si vous allez dans ht
soit un médicament soit même à yahoo
dans un supermarché avec marquez se
produit je sais pas très bien ce qu'être
dans je ne sais pas comment y était fait
je ne sais pas si c'est bon ou mauvais
pour la santé est ce que vous allez le
manger ou est-ce que vous allez prendre
que médicaments non donc il est très
anormal qu'un tel produit serait sur le
marché
on ne sait donc pas grand chose sur ce
nouveau produit
les autorités sanitaires assurent se
pencher sérieusement sur la question
mais pour l'instant cela n'empêche pas
faire buralistes de vendre la cigarette
électronique